McDonald's has elevated shamrock season to new heights...
...with the transcendent line of McCafe beverages combining mint and chocolate flavors.
And every once in a while, along comes something so revolutionary,...
...it changes everything.
This is not that but it's close.
The Chocolate Shamrock Shake:...
...expertly crafted using a dual layer design that combines both a chocolate shake...
...and a mint flavored shake into a single, portable drinking vessel.
But we soon realized a conventional, mono-cylindrical straw...
...simply would not provide the ideal flavor ratio.
Thus, a spectacularly unnecessary product was born.
The suction tube for reverse axial withdrawal,...
...the "Straw".
Conceived, designed and executed by a real team of actual super-duper smart aerospace engineers...
...that McDonald's collaborated with, the straw delivers.
Two shake flavors to your mouth.
Magic.